- We're going to hand over to
these lovely people
that have asked questions.
First up is Michael Carlton.
Whilst we get the mic to
Michael--
(crowd murmuring)
Michael Charlton, forgive me,
whilst we're doing that as well
I want to give an
exceptional shout out to IBM.
Laura, Dave who covered a pound
for every single pound that
everybody spent today.
(applause)
This is Dave's book.
Right hook, behavioral
marketing they are
10 copies to buy here today.
Very happy to give all
the money to charity but
please pick one up.
- I'll buy them.
- Yeah?
- All of them.
- Okay. Done.
Thank you.
First question from our friend
Michael is a cameras on our
friend here so we
can get some shine?
We got one of the official
cameras on our friends here?
- You don't like cameras?
Dude, you're such a
good looking dude.
I'd be on all on that shit.
- My question, I had a
question before I came.
- You did not or you did?
- I didn't.
- And now?
- But I do have one now.
- Yeah.
- When you're discussing
about young people being
entrepreneurs,--
- Yes.
- the space that I work in is
with people at university I do
main club events I train them
up and I've always come to the
point worked for me for like
two years and I've helped them,
improved and they leave, set up
their own rival company
and go after me.
- Fuck you.
- [Michael] And it does me every time.
- Yeah.
- [Michael] I can't get past a point.
And I always tell them
you're going to fail.
You don't know how hard this is.
And the obviously go off and
try it and fail and I'm right--
- But some have won.
- No.
One, the first one but
everybody after that has failed.
- [Gary] Because the first one left,
you got pissed and you're not
teaching them as well anymore.
(laughter)
I know this game.
It's a subconscious
it's not your fault.
You're just a good dude.
You're not a bad guy
it's the subconscious.
- [Michael] My question is--
- [Gary] Bless you.
- Less barriers to entry in
a market if you're training
somebody up and they can leave,
when do you just
stop training them?
- Yeah.
- [Michael] How do
you stop doing that?
- No, it is a great question.
You know, I'm a bad person to
ask because I've done something
so weird.
I've made it so obvious to my
employees, do you know how many
employees have told me the
entire plan, big shout out Gabe,
was to come to Vayner steal
my shit and go do their shit.
And this is not zing on you.
What I am doing I'm making it
so obvious that being number 400
with me will make them more
happiness and money than being
number one with them that they
come in and then they change.
What I think you need to think
about is what can you do to
replicate that feeling if
that's what you want to do.
Or, or you start building up C
players instead of B players.
- [Michael] That's basically
what I've recently done.
- That's gonna work.
- They're C players
they couldn't do anything.
- That's right and
it's gonna work.
If that's your model
those are your two options.
It's either, it's the truth.
It's either becoming a super
A+ yourself or playing with C
players because B's are going
to be vulnerable in the way that
you have described. Cool.
- [Michael] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Thank you very much.
- I love real talk.
Fucking love real talk.
Guys, start demanding
more real talk in
these business fucking lectures.
- Shout out to you there, Michael.
One of the biggest proponents of
VaynerWorld certainly on social
media and especially on Twitter
next question over to
Vicky Funky Fairy.
- Yeah!
- Round of applause for Vicki.
(applause)
Let's get a mic over.
- I know her.
- Look at the t-shirt.
Stand up as well so we
can get you on camera.
- Let's clap it up,
she is a lovely lady.
(applause)
- I forgotten the question, Raj.
- [Raj] All right, freestyle.
- Facebook and Instagram--
- [Gary] Yes.
- Do you see a big difference
between the UK market
and the US market?
- [Gary] No.
(laughter)
- [Vicki] Okay.
The reason why I ask is we
seem to be on this one minute
everybody loves this
with all post
that Mr. Funky Fairy is doing.
Facebook features us as a
success story in terms of that
we're doing really well and
then 48 hours will go by
and then nothing.
Put new adverts out and it
is very, very hit and miss.
- [Gary] You mean
that feed organically?
I'm trying to figure it out.
Help me understand
what you are you asking.
- [Man] We do the adverts
ourselves that we split test,
we do creatives, we do
everything, we've picked the
ones that work and they work
really well so we go down that
line again to a different
audience, do the same thing and
we bomb out.
- Well maybe 'cause a different
audience wasn't the right move.
- [Man] Yes.
We're trying so many
different audiences in
different ways with
different creative.
- What are you trying to
make happen with the content?
Get social engagement
or create a transaction?
- [Man] Transaction.
- Okay.
Listen, I can tell you from a
lot of data there's enormous
amount of transactional
stuff going on in the UK.
Are you saying that the first
thing you did was that going to
your organic audience?
Or is it all advertising?
- [Man] It's all advertising.
- So you did
something and it worked.
- [Man] Yeah.
- And then you try to
do a look-alike
or other segmentation?
- [Man] Yeah.
- There's so many different
reasons that might not be
working, it would probably
take up the rest of the night.
There's a couple of questions
first the depth and the quality
of your product is the
number one variable.
Some products can sell to
everybody in the world, Apple,
and some can sell to six.
That would be the first thing I
would look at if you are hanging
out for six hours of like
how good is your thing really?
Right?
And is the best segmentation
I always say like there's some
businesses that have very small
cohorts that will convert and
the second go out of it nothing
you can do will work because
what you're selling
is not going to sell.
That is my first intuition.
But there's a million other
things but there's definitely
nothing different in the UK or
the US behavior in big data that
makes me think that's the case.
You could, you know, that's it.
I just don't see it.
- [Vicky] We just started on
Instagram.
- [Gary] Instagram ads
are acting funky still.
They're not there yet.
The data is not
mapping to the cohort.
I just ran a piece of content
against 18 to 25-year-old
African-American males and the
comments are 60-year-old white
chicks in there and I'm
like "What the fuck?"
It's not working yet but it's
got the potential to
be a great product.
- Thank you so much.
- The product is really the
thing you have to look because
that's very unusual and the
times I've seen it, it's been
more about the depth of the
product than any other variable
marketing thing.
Those T-shirts Snapchat
bags, Snapchat stuff?
I would, first of all, if you're trying
to sell Snapchat stuff I'd much
recommend more for you to
pay Snapchat influencers to do
product placement
than anything else.
That my first thing.
- [Man] Which you may have
seen already at SXSW.
- [Gary] But the problem is
there's no way to build Snapchat
swag as a business because
there's 900 people that are
doing it. There is no
point of differentiation.
You'll be
completely commoditized.
You're riding a quick wave.
You're making a quick buck,
you're not building a business.
You're building
Snapchat's business.
- True.
Next up and I'm reading this
off handwriting Glenn Elliott.
Is that right, Sujen?
- [Sujen] Yes, it is.
- Where is Glenn Elliott?
Glenn Elliot, thank you
for buying 50 books mate.
Appreciate it.
- Glenn, thank you
for buying 50 books.
Very handsome.
- What's your advice on building
a great culture in your company?
- [Gary] What is my
advice for building
great content in your company?
- [Glenn] Great culture.
- Culture.
I've got a lot on this and
honestly this is probably the
place where I can see myself
going more and more because soon
Vayner is really, really, really
going to be big and it's going
to be really because of this.
And then I'll feel
confident that
I'm allowed to talk about it.
I started talking about it
a little bit because we're
starting to get big.
First and foremost, are
you the partner, CEO?
Is it your business?
- Yeah.
- First and foremost, you have
to realize in a real way,
in a non-bullshit way
that you work for them.
If you do not do
that you've lost.
If you think people work for you
as the CEO or the founder of a
company versus you working for
them you will never ever, ever,
ever, ever, ever, zoom in, ever,
ever, ever, ever, ever, ever,
ever, ever build a good
culture in a company.
That's number one.
That is religious.
That is number one.
Got it?
Number two, you have to realize
that there is no blanket rules.
Everybody in your company,
how many employees do you have?
- [Glenn] 330.
- [Gary] 330.
Great, nice number.
You have to micromanage 330
people's wants, ambitions and
needs on an everyday basis
predicated on what else is
happening in their lives
day after day, month after month,
year after year.
So what that means is he
may be motivated by money.
I love when people are
like Millenials are so zen.
I have Millennials who literally
would rather work an extra 20
hours for six more bucks.
They love money.
You have to figure
out what drives them?
Is it money?
Is it work-life balance?
Are they a huge Chelsea fan and
you buy them random tickets when
they aren't looking and the
like, "Oh my God, you actually
know something about me."
Right?
You think I pay
attention a lot to you guys?
I fucking stalk the
shit out of my
650 employees on social media.
(laughter)
I know who fucking loves Tinder.
I know who loves bourbon.
I know it all.
And so it's very hard to scale
one-on-one context
with 330 employees.
The other thing is you
have to build infrastructure.
Last Friday I announced a new
role that I announced was the
most senior role in the company
besides me, more senior than AJ.
More senior than
James Orsini, my right hand guy.
More senior than my CFO.
Who is Claude Silver, who is
now my partner basically in the
company and she is the
Chief Heart Officer.
She will help me scale the
mapping of one-to-one at scale.
Because you know Rick who
wants money at 22 to 24
to 27 might want something else
when he gets engaged
because his partner
wants him home on the weekends
and he used to want to work and
make money so he would
work on Saturday and
now he doesn't want to.
Or scarier shit that I'm always
mentally prepared for which is a
tragedy may
happen in your family.
And you have to
leave for nine months.
And you come back shaken.
The only way to build great
culture is not only through
words that are written on the
wall, but in your actions you
have to make every one of those
people understand that you care
more about them than you
want them to care about you.
It is the only way.
(applause)
And I swear I'm trying
to do it at a level that's never
been done before.
But wherever I land,
is what I will have.
If I my 92 and the market's a
67, that's incredible, right?
You can't be
crippled by the task.
What I just said some people get
crippled when I tell them that
advise on 13 employees.
You got 330, my man.
I got 650.
It's tough but if you do it,
you will build great culture.
And if you don't, every step of
the way that you do less of it
you will have less
of that culture.
- [Glenn] Thank you.
- You got it.
(applause)
And it's about allocating the
dollars the right things.
One of the best things I do is
the most talented people in my
company, if they are not bought
into being the bigger woman and
bigger man in every situation
I don't care for the number one
salesperson, the best creative
director they are fucking fired.
Right?
And you have to be
religious about that.
The second you let somebody
get away with something
you will lose.
And then meritocracy.
We started the company with
eight of AJ's friends.
Some of them are the number
10 most important and well
compensated employee and
some of them are number 387.
Meritocracy.
Right?
If you take care of your
nephew better than somebody
who is hustling,
you've died.
You're done, your culture's broke.
You let something
beside meritocracy rule.
- Fantastic.
- Belarus.
The last place that lets
meritocracy, the last place.
The last dictatorship in Europe.
Woo.
- [Raj] Next up
is Adrian Savage.
Thank you for buying 50 books.
Adrian, please put
your hand up or stand up.
- [Gary] Adrian.
(applause)
- [Adrian] Hey Gary.
- How are you?
- [Adrian] Great, thanks.
I saw you at the InfusionSoft
event three weeks ago.
- In San Diego?
- [Adrian] In Phoenix.
- Phoenix, right thank you.
- [Adrian] I previously seen you
four years before that
in Phoenix as well.
- Phoenix is our spot bro.
- [Adrian] It is man.
- [Gary] See you in four years.
- Yeah, definitely.
You really hit me in the heart
last time and the way
that you didn't before.
And I started really think about
the content for the first time.
- [Gary] Yes.
- The other thing that you hit
me with is that audience was an
audience of transactors.
- [Gary] Yes.
- They are my audience,
they are my business,
they are my customers.
- Yes.
- [Adrian] How quickly
are they likely to change?
How much I need to change to
accommodate that and bear in
mind now I've realized something
about content for the first time
what else should I be doing
differently to take to give them
the best value that I can?
- Well, I appreciate
you saying that.
Hold onto the mic.
I think that was interesting talk
because just to give you guys
context, digital marketing a
lot of people are in
performance marketing.
And they think
they are marketing.
Really performance is sales.
They're in performance sales.
Right?
You caught a good long term
Google ad that is converting.
You found an arbitrage on
a cohort on a Facebook ad.
It's transactional.
And I'm glad you caught that.
I felt really good about that
talk because you know as well as
I do that was an
interesting talk.
Right?
- [Adrian] It really was.
- I came in and 98% of the
audience was doing one thing and
I told him that was rubbish
and I told them more importantly
that that thing was not only
rubbish, that it was in deep
danger over the next 3 to 4
years which is true because a
lot of people, as you know, as I
know, in that room transact in a
desktop internet world.
This shit right here, my
man, this shit is extinct.
I don't even know,
what the fuck is this?
This is over.
The reason I went at it is this
is over because this is here.
- [Adrian] Yep.
- The fact that I now business
travel with only my phone and do
all of my work on
it, it's crazy.
I don't have a
laptop bag anymore.
It's so weird.
Your email capture
pop up on desktop
is kind of fucked up but
acceptable because at least
there's other real estate.
On this fucking
thing, not as good.
All of your behaviors.
How long?
I don't know.
But my intuition is a lot of
people are quite vulnerable
because arbitrage and your move
and your Commission Junction
move that worked, died.
Your Google Adwords thing died.
A lot of those
people get flushed out.
For you, when I do your
customers, I like that because
I said to myself if he's seen the
light what you need to do is you
need to become a media company.
You need to put up great content
and not about what you do.
Let's say you do tax SaaS.
Let's say what you did and I'm
sure that's not it but let's say
you sell software that
helps people that are digital
marketers do taxes.
What you need to do is help, put
out content not about taxes but
about running a business,
about managing your will,
the other things that that
person cares about.
Got it?
- [Adrian] Yeah.
- You need to think about your
content directly with what you
do but more broadly so
you become a value to them.
And then you have leverage.
And that's what I try to
do with my content, right?
I'm trying to talk
about a lot of things.
I've really opened it up with
this emotional intelligence
because it's an equal part of
running a business and that's me
broadening and bringing value
so I would tell you in
podcast form,
writing on medium.com,
in video form,
Snapchat form
whatever's most comfortable to
you to communicate to the world
you need to become
a media company.
As a matter of fact, every
single person in this room needs
to become a media
company, comma, you sell shit.
Wine business back there,
big shout out, wine brand,
be a media company
first, then sell wine.
If you're educating people about
wine culture and about cheese
and about travel, you then build
equity to be able to transact on
your wine.
But nobody's thinking that way.
They're thinking so narrow and so
transactional and what happens
with transactions is when
there's a shift in platform,
they die.
Because they did not build the
brand and they don't translate.
I jump back on Snapchat,
there's 20,000 people ready
for me to go.
That's brand.
Every platform I sign up for, if
I want to not do it right away
there's a queue of people
ready to hear from me.
People squat GaryVee now on
every social network that pops
up and then send me an email
like, "GaryVee I took your name.
If you give me an hour
I'll give it to you."
I'm like, "Fuck you,
I'm gonna get it."
(laughter)
Anyway, brand.
Brands survive.
Nike didn't tag,
Nike didn't cookie
my browser and follow me
around the internet and
make me eventually buy Nikes.
I buy Nikes
because they branded me.
- [Adrian] Got it. Perfect.
(applause)
Thanks Gary
(applause drowns out sound)
- I'm sorry?
- [Adrian] Since I came back
from the US I've written my
first few bits of content.
You've inspired me to start
moving in that direction.
Thank you.
- How's it feel?
- [Adrian] It feels good.
It feels bloody good.
- Yeah?
Did anything interesting happen?
Sometimes it
takes in six months.
Did anything weird happened
where you were like, "oh shit"?
- [Adrian] I started to realize
I could do it and there was
actually something
holding me back.
And then suddenly
get it out there--
- And some dude stood on stage
and punched you in the mouth and
you did it.
(laughter)
- [Adrian] Yeah, pretty much.
Also, I now really understand
what you say when
your comments are oxygen.
I really get that now because
I'm starting to get that feedback.
- [Gary] And you know
what that feedback does?
It helps you strategize.
One of the selfish things with
the #AskGaryVee stuff is
I'm learning what people
are thinking predicated
on what they're asking.
It's a scaled
version of listening.
- [Adrian] That is brilliant.
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Next up is Frank Wesley.
- Frank!
- [Raj] Did I pronounce
that right, Frank Wesley?
- There's the man.
- [Raj] Let's get the mic over.
- [Frank] West Ham fan.
Gary, hi.
- [Gary] How are you?
- I'm very well.
You need to
support West Ham United.
- Is that where you want to go?
(cheers and boos)
- Wow.
Have you won a
championship in 25 years?
- We are shit.
Don't worry about it.
- [Gary] Shit?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- I'm interested.
Get me more data.
- I had a question while I've
been watching you tonight
I'm now going to ask
a different one.
- [Gary] Okay.
- What got me into your content
was the rant that you came out
with for the
older entrepreneurs.
- [Gary] Yes.
(cheers)
- And I followed you
avidly since then.
You talked a little while ago
about a 19-year-old entrepreneur--
- [Gary] Yes.
- their biggest asset is patience.
- What is the
older entrepreneur?
What should they
have as their asset?
'Cause I'm not patient.
Three years ago, I started a
business with some other guys
we're now 80 people
turning over £10 million.
- [Gary] Amazing.
- [Frank] I am not patient.
- You want more.
- Absolutely.
It's fantastic.
- [Gary] It is amazing.
- What's my biggest asset now?
- Well I think your asset
is all the cliché stuff.
It's just cliché.
Everybody said it.
What I think though is do
I think instead of saying
"experience" I'm going to
tweak it a little bit.
Do I think a 46-year-old man
has a better chance of knowing
himself than a 19-year-old man?
Yes, I do. I think we've all
gone through it, right?
Even think about your transition
from high school to university.
You just get there.
You get more comfortable
with yourself.
The second you get more
comfortable with yourself
you start being
more honest with yourself.
So at this point in your life,
and my life and your life
we should really know ourselves.
And so it's even interesting for
me to hear that you started
with a couple other gentlemen.
To me, my hope for my own kind
of personal picture that I'm
trying to paint here is that the
three of you had some crossover
skills but you're all
maintaining your core skill and
that is what's
helping the business.
You're taking care of this, that
person is taking care of that,
and the other person is there.
That's a very common thing for
older entrepreneurs because at
that point they've shed their
wants and their romance about
being the best sales guy or the
best sales girl and now they know
I'm really good at
CFO, finances
I'll never let us go
out of business.
I got the numbers.
Don't worry guys.
You go be crazy 'cause I'm gonna
make sure that we pay our bills.
You go make sure the staff
loves us and now we've got this.
I was gifted that I do a
lot of the principles well.
All of them.
Finance probably being my
weakest, it's probably the one
that's most commoditized
and when you're
in business with
your dad and your brother
if they steal from you
it's a good story.
(laughter)
I think that your biggest
advantage is that you got,
it's probably the narrative
to why you are succeeding.
Now the question becomes
a more interesting one.
I'm going to take you in a
different place that's probably
more grounded in
the actual energy.
I think the big thing now at
this point in your life is to
really try to figure out very
quickly what you want to happen.
And the problem is you have
two other people that may want
different things.
But if you're able to align
that you guys want to sell the
company soon because that's a
real cash out on that kind of
revenue then all of your
behaviors have
to go in that direction.
You have to the figure
who you can sell to you,
you have to start becoming a
media company to them.
One of the great misplays of
brand is if I wanted to sell
VaynerMedia tomorrow it
would happen in 30 minutes
not on revenue, on the fact that
I would market to the people
that could actually by me.
I don't think Martin Sorrell
knows who I am, in 20 minutes he
would want to rip his
arm off the buy us.
That's what I'm good at.
What I would love to know is how
aligned are you guys and
if you're aligned make all your
actions go in that direction.
That's interesting to me.
Right?
That's where you can be
something amazing happen.
So I think that's something to
really give some
serious thought to.
But I think it's
self-awareness at this point.
You got so much more
history in your 20, 30 years of
entrepreneurship that allows you
to and you should shed whatever
pride you have left in
principles that you don't bring
to the table as well as you know
partners do, the more you could
shed down to only
focusing on what you do.
Me and AJ are so efficient 'cause
we do not discuss the things
that we know the other
person is better at.
We don't even talk about it.
You know?
Big.
When one broaches the
subject the other gets pissed.
Right?
'Cause why would
he even waste time?
You know I'm better
at this than you and
we've become efficient.
Like fucking
efficient, you know?
And time is the asset.
So why debate?
Got it?
- Yeah, that's great.
That's great.
We're on the path--
- [Gary] And the other
thing I would tell you I would
highly recommend that you
forcing your other two partners
to over communicate with the
three of you at all times.
Force communication, right now.
You're successful and
you're at this age.
This is an interesting time.
Force communication.
Anything that you think is
sitting in your heart that needs
to be talked about with the
other two partners I would tell
you to do that tomorrow.
The quicker you get it out,
the better you're gonna be.
- [Frank] Yeah, thank you, Gary.
- You're welcome.
(applause)
- [Raj] The final 50 book
purchase question is going out
to a gentleman by the
name of Luke Johnson.
Please stand up Luke Johnson.
- Luke.
Let's all say Luke.
- [Crowd] Luke.
- Cheers, Gary.
That might catch on.
Gary, I've changed my mind about
the question a ton of times so
I'm Luke, founder of
Shredded by Science.
We're an online education
provider for personal trainers.
- [Gary] Okay.
- I know that Mike has done a
superb job getting shredded.
- [Gary] Yes.
- What up, Mike
wherever Mike is?
- [Gary] Good job, Mike.
- [Luke] Let's give Mike a round
of applause for the bananas.
(applause)
So in regards to you
said you know
where things are going to go in
the next 10 to 15 years
where do you see
the fitness industry?
Is that the online coaching and
everyone wants to
be an online coach.
And this passive income where
we know it's not passive income.
Where do you see maybe VR or
the fitness industry going?
I know you've mentioned about
entrepreneur tendencies
natural for a personal trainer.
- I don't think I know where
things are going 10 to 15 years
I think I have intuitions and I
think what I'm really good at is
moving fast when I see it.
So that's number one.
Look, I mean fitness is gonna
only going to continue to grow.
Meditation I think is one
of the great open spaces.
I think the amount of money
that's going to be made in
meditation is
going to be enormous.
Just enormous.
I think meditation is no
question is the next
eating healthy and working out.
A mental health is going
to become a much bigger
conversation and meditation is
at the forefront--
- [Woman] Alright!
(applause)
I think that's one thing
that is very clear to me.
As far as physical and things of
that nature, look, I mean it's
never going to go away.
It's only going to grow.
Supply and demand
is gonna happen.
It's not it's very low cost
of entry to get into the game.
I'd like to think that the
market weeds itself out from
people that are, I look at
fitness very similar to the way
I look at entrepreneurship.
There's a ton of hucksters.
Their entire
marketing strategy is
taking cute selfies
to put on Instagram.
Which is fine.
And quite enjoyable in
a lot of ways but--
- A lot easier
when you're female.
- I mean look 'cause dudes
are scum buckets so that's why.
I think that I'd like to think
that the people that deserve to
win are gonna win because they
continued to try to refine their
craft and add nutrition into
their game, educate themselves
but passive income when you're
online coaching you're not going
to keep anybody as an online
coach if you try to make it
passive because you're not going
to be giving them anything.
Mike's stopping taking clients.
He does not want anymore.
He's at the prime of his game
and he doesn't want to hire
people underneath them to scale.
And he is stretched.
He's stretched.
So it only scales so
much if you do it right.
Or you can trick people for a
few minutes and you get top line
revenue but then you have no
lifetime value and they go away.
And so what?
You're just going to go to the
bottom and trick people and not
feel good about yourself and
make money in a bullshit way?
Cool, fine.
I actually fundamentally predict
that it's going to look a lot
the same we're just going to
be doing in different places.
Sure, we'll do VR and then
people are gonna look good in
real life versus
looking good on Instagram.
Some people play on vanity and
I'd like to think that it will
go through a cleansing where
people get exposed for not
providing the right value.
Some people are just genetically
inclined and are in great shape
to begin with and then they just
arb what mom and dad gave them
to the marketplace and
that sucks but whatever.
I think it looks pretty
much the same. Really I do.
You want it? Go ahead.
- Just because I know you're
opening up a London office and
I wanted to the amount of value
provided me a business and to my
team I'd love to maybe come
with the team and do mentorship
training thing.
- [Gary] You got
to talk to Mike.
He's in charge.
Mike's the CEO.
- Cool.
- [Gary] I'd charm him.
- [Raj] Fantastic. Thank you.
- Did that extra banana
get into Gary's macros?
- He lets me.
It's okay when I
cheat with fruit.
Thanks Mike you're
real fucking sport.
(laughter)
- [Sujen] I'm
running to the back.
- I was going to say go to the
back somebody who's been kind
enough or stand up
for whatever reason.
Went out to the back.
General entry tickets
make some noise.
(cheers)
This guy just
he snitched on himself.
He's got a general entry
ticket and sat up
in the premium section.
- You're a real douche bag.
(laughter)
- Okay, come on.
- Hi Gary, Bina.
No bullshit, I didn't
actually know who you were
before I came here today.
- [Gary] Fuck.
- Sorry about that.
- [Gary] I'm kidding,
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
By the way, no bullshit,
that's always way better
than the reverse.
I love it. Go ahead.
- [Bina] I came with a friend.
But I am glad I did.
I'm really, really glad I did.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- I guess it's a bit deep for
me but I guess I feel like
I've grown up in a box.
I was told to go to
university, get a degree.
- [Gary] Yep.
- Get married, have a
house and have children.
- [Gary] I understand.
- And I'm brown so that
way kind of the way
our lives are dictated.
- [Gary] Yes.
It wasn't recommended.
- And I guess like you I grew up,
I did a paper round,
I washed cars,
I cleaned houses, I ironed.
And now I've given up my
full-time job, I was a lawyer.
And now I am entrepreneur.
- [Gary] Yes.
- We borrow and we
rent out Indian clothing.
Now what I find difficult
sometimes is having the
resilience, the patience and the
drive of ambition to keep going,
to strive even when you get
knocked down and even when I'm
put up against all this pressure
from my parents, my friends to
get a job, you know, have a
stable job, have a stable income,
it's just about keeping going.
- [Gary] I'm listening.
- So what I'm wondering is
what keeps you,
what kept you motivated?
What kept you going?
What kept you inspired?
- So it is interesting when you
are talking, you're like
"Now, I'm an entrepreneur"
and I was laughing,
you've always been
an entrepreneur.
You got forced to
do the other thing.
No little girl is running around
and doing a paper route
that's not an entrepreneur.
Do you do know what I mean?
You know, what kept me going
is I would suffocate
if I did anything else.
And I have a funny
feeling you would too.
So you're more than welcome to
not breathe as easy and
go that route or do you.
That's on you.
Listen, hit me up on fuckin'
every social network,
I'll tell you every day go
do your thing go, go.
I'm thrilled.
I love being a cheerleader.
I feel like I got so gifted
by having a cheerleader in my
mother that I almost feel guilty
how good I had it that I want to
give it to you.
That's why I love
interacting with so many of you.
I don't like the motivational
part of me because I don't want
to go down that guru path but
I'm thrilled to provide it when
I think somebody needs it.
What kept me going was there
was no fucking other alternative.
Literally, and I am not joking,
I'd rather die
than not be an entrepreneur.
Die. Die.
So what was I going to do?
Kill myself?
No way.
You have to understand
there was no option.
I didn't respect anybody else's
opinion enough to even let it be
a consideration.
- [Bina] Thank you.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
(applause)
- [Man] Hi Gary, it's Lloyd
from Skybury Customer
Service Experts.
- [Gary] How are you?
- I'm good, thank you.
I'm good.
I'm wearing my suit and
hopefully I'll get noticed.
- [Raj] Can we do
something about that feedback?
- [Gary] You wore a suit to get
noticed because you thought a
lot of other people
wouldn't wear a suit?
- No, it's a checked suit so
maybe someone would pass the mic
to me because I'm
wearing an unusual suit.
- [Gary] I think you were right.
- Thank you, Gary.
- You're a
fucking growth hacker.
- [Lloyd] Thank you very much.
Thank you.
No, no one else got that.
I love the new Anchor app and
I think it has a big future in
customer service as a
customer service platform--
- [Gary] Okay.
- Because the conversational
style and that you can actually
use audio and your
voice and empathy.
I think it would be good for
businesses and I just wondered
what your thoughts are
for the future of Anchor?
- So as you know or you may know
I've been very curious about it.
I've been using it.
I've been talking about it,
I've seen a lot of you
adopt it as well.
And this is very similar to what
I did with Snapchat
and other platforms.
I think voice is a
very big platform.
I think it is quite convenient
I love how they did it.
You just put it up to your ear
right, they've done a lot of
things right with the product.
I love how you onboard.
But now that I've decided it's
good, now I don't pay attention.
Now I wait.
So I already believe it is good.
But now I need to know
if you think it is good.
- I do.
- And when I say you
I don't mean you, dick.
I mean the market.
The you.
- [Lloyd] Fair enough. Okay.
- It's not going to mean jack
shit to customer service if
nobody's on it.
Got it?
- [Lloyd] Fair point.
- [Gary] I think it is good.
I like it.
Now I have to wait for it to
have 25 million users
then I'll pay attention.
- Okay.
- [Gary] Awesome.
- Thanks.
- [Gary] Yeah.
(applause)
- [Man] Hey Gary
my name is Ryan.
I teach creativity through
super consciousness and--
- [Gary] Through
super consciousness?
- Yeah.
- I'm pumped right now.
What does that?
No, no.
I actually don't
know what that is.
What is that?
- Basically, I believe there's
a lot of unconscious activities
going around the world.
- [Gary] I believe that too.
- Brussels being one of
the examples of that.
- [Gary] Explain.
No, no explain.
- Unconsciously I believe that
we have an illusion that we're
separate and actually that there
is mother fuckers going out
there trying to get selfish
agendas resolved when actually
we all here to create and create
from a place of service in
relationship to each other.
- [Gary] Okay.
- I'm not pro- or anti-
the guru thing.
I do seminars, I speak
all that kind of stuff.
It's good to hear somebody
swear as much as I do on stage.
I get a lot of stick for that.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- But my thing is I actually
feel strongly against a lot of
the so-called gurus
out there in the world.
Self-help, personal development.
- [Gary] Okay.
- I kind of get torn between
sticking to my guns, sticking to
my product and my service which
does really well which is why
I'm a bit tired.
Got a load of great customers.
And then taking a directive
particularly on social media
where I specifically point
out gaps in the bull shit
philosophies that are
being taught to people.
- [Gary] Okay.
- That actually
don't get results.
For me, if someone comes to
my event and they don't get a
result, I want to
give their money back.
- [Gary] Okay.
- Whether I think they fucked
up or not, doesn't matter.
- [Gary] Okay.
- [Ryan] I think there's a lot
going on the world today where
people are just
rinsing people for money.
Because they believe
they're gurus. They're getting--
- [Gary] Good news.
Not just today.
It is always happened.
Keep going.
- And so my question is do I
keep gunning and just doing my
products and keeping quiet to
myself or do I go on a bit of an
attack but with a smile?
- Well I think, I mean,
I think that is a
very personal question.
I don't know.
For what?
Because you want to
clean up the space?
- What I find is that sometimes
and depending on the audience
intuitively I don't
go on an attack.
- [Gary] Yep.
- And then
sometimes intuitively I do.
It kind of works,
it's a balance.
So I was just wondering I love
your aggressive stance and your
directness and so I'm a direct
person but that does ruffle a
few feathers along
the way particularly--
- [Gary] Yeah, I don't give a
talk about anybody's feathers.
- Great me too.
I'm actually allergic to fucking
feathers so there you go.
- Good.
I fucking, to me,
I think it has to come from
what really drives you, right?
Nobody should decide
what your path is on that.
- [Ryan] Yeah, appreciate that.
- You got it.
- [Raj] We're probably good for
about three more so that we can
get everyone's books signed--
- [Sujen] Did
you say three more?
- Three more, yeah.
And they we're going to take a
three, four minute gap and then
set up the book signing.
So for the next three
questions make them good.
- Practicing.
- Also, make them questions,
make them punchy in questions.
- Don't judge
people's questions.
- I'm not judging them.
- Let's go.
Let's go.
- Be quiet. Gary said so.
Lisa Nichols UK, love you and
all that stuff that
you've heard before.
I just wanted to say something
from a mother of children with
special needs.
That you've given me permission
to not send them to university
and not and not and not and
not and who would've thought?
So I love your I'm 52 1/2
and I can if I want to.
Love that.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- I'm not an entrepreneur,
I'm self-employed.
- [Gary] Yes.
- [Lisa] I don't hustle.
I've got kids and I want
to be there for pickup.
- Yep.
- [Lisa] And I just do
the little bit that I do.
- You do your hustle.
- [Lisa] And I enjoy that.
- [Gary] Yep.
- It's not I'm sorry Raj, thank
you so much for doing tonight.
I just want to tell Gary the
bit about EQ is so important.
So thank you so
much for doing that.
My husband is a
public school bully.
He was well educated same place
as Stephen Hawking and he says
to the children,
"Well why don't you?
I was nickels at my
school," and I'm like fuck you.
- Yeah.
(laughter)
- [Lisa] And you given me the
permission to let my girls be my
girls so I'm sorry that's not a
question but I had to tell you.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you so much.
- [Raj] Thank you so much.
(cheers and applause)
- Send your husband my way.
Send him.
- I have never been as popular
as when I have a mic for people
to ask you a question.
And genuinely, I hate saying no
to people, can you pick the last
two people because...?
- Pick the guy with the record
because I like the way he's been
trying to hack that.
- I'm Golden Disc Dave from
TheGoldDisc.com and you can
follow me
@TheGoldDisc everywhere.
I'm looking, I'm 53.
- [Gary] You look good.
- We're in a minority.
The over 50s here.
I make shit.
- [Gary] Yep.
- I make stuff.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- And I just want
to find another way.
- [Gary] To sell it?
- [Man] We do things the number
one that you're on day you were
born which is yours.
- Thank you very much.
What was it?
- If you want to
pass that forward.
- [Gary] Thank you.
What was number one?
- [Raj] We're about to find out.
- Find out.
And we do them the number one
on the day that you were born
and we do wedding first dances.
But they tend to be
one off purchases.
- Yeah.
Have you run Facebook ads?
- [Dave] Some, yes.
- What's going on?
Are you good at it?
- I'm not good at it.
I'm 53.
- [Gary] I don't give a fuck.
(laughter)
That is not the right excuse.
- [Dave] But--
- That's not the right excuse.
I understand about that,
I figured that part out.
What was it?
- Don't, don't, don't.
- You say it.
You say it.
- The number one, how timely,
"Space Oddity" by David Bowie.
(cheers)
- I love it. I love it.
- [Dave] And it's
green for the Jets.
- I love it. Thank you.
So first of all, you're 53.
It's your business?
- [Dave] It's my business.
- Good.
- [Dave] It's my passion.
- Great. Even better.
- [Dave] I love it.
- Great.
Facebook.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- You will kill with it.
- [Dave] Do I need to do video?
- No.
You need to target people
that were born in 1975
with 1975 shit.
- Okay.
- [Gary] You will kill with it.
A company called Buzzfeed
fundamentally built an empire on
the back of that targeting.
I don't want to hear that I am
not good on it 'cause you're 53.
- [Dave] But I love it.
I follow you.
- You can follow fucking
Gandhi I don't give a fuck.
(laughter).
I want you to be
good at it because
do you know what a layup is?
I don't know if you
guys use that slang.
It's a fucking layup.
Your business that is targeted
on a one-to-one basis is
insanely easy to convert on
Facebook if you gave it more
than a bullshit try.
- [Dave] (inaudible).
- God bless.
God bless.
Listen. There's 70--
- I'm going to be a busy guy.
- There's 70 million people that
can fucking... It's a layup,
you have to figure it out.
If you do it, your business will
go tremendously well and
you'll have more time
to do your passion.
- Cheers Gary.
- [Gary] Cheers.
- Back the Potters.
You need to follow Stoke City.
Check out Stoke City.
West Ham have won a
cup for fuck's sake.
- Respect. Respect.
- Last question of the evening--
- I want to go with that dude
all the way in the corner who
never thought he was gonna have
a chance to ask a question.
- Who are we looking at?
- That, yeah.
Yep, you.
- Okay.
- Gary, how are you doing?
- [Gary] Psst. Psst.
Gary, Jay here from Two Fresh.
- [Gary] Psst. Psst. Psst.
- One second.
- Want me to sign it?
- Can I sit on the stage
so I can be the first one?
- Yes.
Yes. Sit.
- Thank you so much.
- Sit.
(laughter)
- I'm sitting on the stage.
- Alright go ahead.
- [Woman on Stage] Can I
can promote something?
- No, you can promote.
You got to fucking sit, relax.
(laughter)
Alright my man.
- I run a video
marketing agency, Gary.
- Very good.
- And we're so passionate about
Facebook video ads at the minute
because of how
targeted they can be.
- [Gary] 'Kay.
- Do you think that's were going
to be all the attention goes in
terms of video content
and spending money
on video marketing?
- Not all but a fuckload.
- Do you see it in terms of
taking over YouTube as the
number one player in
terms of content as well?
- Not taking over but
taking a ton of market share.
- So you definitely recommend to
keep focusing and specializing
in that skill and
promoting that to our clients?
- Yes but also start building
skills to make video
for native Snapchat.
- [Jay] Thank you. Big fan.
Appreciate it.
- You're welcome.
(applause)